i i gotta ask you have you guys ever had
that the other way around where you've
been the nervous wreck
meeting someone i've had that once i've
had like a fanboy
why's maybelline laughing yeah why are
you laughing
we know you've been there that's just
mainly this is you in general yeah
i've had that i've never understood like
the fanboy moment in my life
until maybe i think it was two or three
years ago i don't know if i told them
the podcast or whatever but
i was at uh otakuthon in uh in montreal
yeah canada
and i was a guest there and one of the
other guests
was obatatakishi who was the illustrator
for death note
and like you know pokemon and you know
based on that
and he was a guest and i knew he was a
guest
right but there were lots of guests at
that convention yeah so i was like
i know he's a guest but i'm it's such a
massive con like i'm probably not going
to see him
yeah so we went to the opening ceremony
because we had to go to the open
ceremony of course he wasn't at the
opening ceremony too busy for that it
was too busy
right so i'm just like it's whatever
like you know i might see a poster of
him somewhere or whatever
yeah i'll i'll i'll see him i'll see him
in the description
when you're two guests like at a
convention that means nothing no no no
no no
i know i know yeah he's like he's he
doesn't seem like the kind of guy who i
was just like
in the green room right like he's he's
going to have like his own room yeah he
was easily like the biggest guest
so i was like okay that's cool i mean
it's cool that i'm in the same building
as him or whatever but
it's whatever if i don't see him totally
fine yeah so
uh we finished the opening ceremony and
we're walking towards
uh our first panel and i think aki was
with me and she and she was like
joey you should you should you should
turn around like why
and he's like because look at the guy
who's like directly behind you
and i turned around and i was all
watching just kind of standing there
he's just like
kind of looking at me yeah like silently
and immediately because he's
he has such a dis because he's like he's
got like a bald head right like very
distinct looking dude and i immediately
knew i'm like
holy [ __ ] that's all about tataki and
anybody would tell you
if you're a guest at a con with oba
tatakishi that is like the most
optimal moment to be like
perfect it was the perfect timing to be
like i'm a guest at this con too yeah
i'm a massive fan of your work whatever
i couldn't say anything i legit was like
i was and that and at that moment i was
like oh my god this is the fanboy moment
i understand it now like you really
can't say anything yeah
you just get it that was the that was
the definition of just
dumbstruck yeah right yeah yeah because
i think i was so caught off guard that i
i didn't expect him to be
literally standing right here looking at
me yeah i don't know why he was looking
at me
like silently he was like yeah he was
like
did you speak to him at all no no i
would have loved to speak english i know
i know i should have i missed that
opportunity i regretted to this day
because i've had like a similar
experience when i first moved to japan
right and it was when melin took me to a
hiroyuki sawano concert
um so we go we go to this hiroyuki
samurai concert and it's
not the type of concert you think it's
going to be right when i heard hiroyuki
sawano concert i'm like
big bass big drum
no it was like at this really really
posh jazz bar
oh and it wasn't i wouldn't even call it
a concert because everyone had like
everyone had like tables and like posh
little cocktails
and he was just like playing a lot of
like acoustic versions
of what he was you know off a lot of the
songs
that's pretty cool yeah of a lot of
songs he's composed so it was it was
like it was more like
it was more like a private jazz bar kind
of deal but it was still [ __ ] amazing
yeah um and so after the concert
uh melian like asked me hey do you want
to meet him
and i was just like so unprepared
i was like i thought i was just going
there to see one of my favorite anime
composers
yeah i wasn't i wasn't i didn't know
malian had like all the [ __ ] contacts
that could get me
which now now knowing her now of course
she does but back then because this was
when i
had just moved to japan yeah um and so
we go
we go uh to like the green room room or
whatever and i'm like waiting outside
and i'm just like
holy [ __ ] get me breathing i'm not just
like i i have i haven't
i haven't emotionally prepared myself
yeah what am i gonna do what am i gonna
say
and like that like i was like reciting
all like the basic [ __ ] japanese that
i know at the time
to like be like like okay i just need to
say something i need to say
something and then so he comes out
i'm like it's here you can know it's
here no
and then so here i'll say do you want to
join a picture and everything and i'm
like
yeah sure sure i'll have a picture so
uh so we take the picture and then i was
like i just wanted to say
i i want in my mind i wanted to say oh
thank you
very much for like your work and
everything you've done yeah didn't
[ __ ] say anything
and so he like after the picture i just
i'm just staring at him like this
and he looks up and he looks at maelyn
and then he just like was that it
okay i'm just going to go back now and
then he goes back to the green room and
i'm just like
oh [ __ ] i was that guy
oh no oh my god that's why
that's the thing though right it's like
now that i've experienced that moment
yeah i don't blame anybody who does that
to like me or like their families
exactly i completely understand how it
feels like
everything you recite in your head just
goes out the [ __ ] window yeah yeah
i've never had that really never really
i think maybe
i'm trying to think who would maybe like
iraqi would i'd be like
yeah oh yeah but like that's like maybe
it like i don't know i've
i don't know like i i it's weird i i see
people who are maybe like
big things and stuff that i like and i'm
just kind of like that's really cool
yeah
i should say hi like uh i was at a con
and um
billy west the guy voices like fry yeah
yeah drama and like did like some of the
looney tunes like the later ones
yeah like like one of the most iconic
voice actors right i was like i mean i
grew up on all that stuff yeah and i was
like
hi man nice to meet you we just like
cause he was in the same green room so
we were just talking about stuff but i
was never like
i was like this guy's so cool and i like
remember his voice and stuff i don't
know it's weird
i guess because i don't in that moment
when i see them in person normally i
don't think about their like work i'm
just like
this is another person in front of me
right i'm going to talk to them like
that
but maybe if it's like someone again
like iraqi or i'm obsessed with yeah
i think it's also for me at least it was
like language barrier because i knew
that's going to be
there were so many things i wanted to
say to him and if you guys could speak
japanese
i was like either i look like a nervous
wreck or i look like a nervous wreck
speaking
broken japanese i don't know what's
better yeah because in english it's like
it's very like you play like a word
yeah you're like you don't want to say
i'm a fan yeah because especially with
other youtubers right yeah
you don't want to say i'm an admirer
because that's just kind of crazy i
normally say like my go-to is yeah man
dude i love your work
yeah sick yeah i usually say like i
appreciate your work like i think the
one guest i got on immediately well with
was uh
the first time i met kevin penkin who
was like such a [ __ ] lad
yeah but to be fair like you're just
nauseous yeah yeah that's the thing it's
like if you didn't know who this guy was
you'd be like oh it's just another
aussie
no he totally is there's like this
mutual like just
like understanding that i feel like
british people and australian people
have when they're meets like we're gonna
get drunk right like yeah yeah we're
getting drunk oh that's sick we're gonna
yeah
as an american i feel like there's a lot
more like juggling involved yeah so
you you do you drink
how much do you drink do you like body
and everything because like
have you met a ton of americans that
just don't drink yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah
and you can never tell right it makes us
sound like alcoholics i was like no we
have to drink
no we are alcoholics yeah it's ingrained
in our culture where
if i meet like a fellow brit or an
aussie it's drinking right it's it's
just like hey i'm having like i'm having
some drinks later it's not even like
it's just an assumption that they will
join
we're one step away in like britain and
australia we're one step away from
the point of if you don't drink we're
gonna bully you
it's like it's that ingrained in our
culture whereas whenever i meet someone
american like an american guest or
someone or something and i want to get
to know them better
i'm like what's what's the best way to
approach this do i ask them out for like
lunch or i don't know drinks
yeah there isn't that same assumption
that you're just going to go out for
drinks afterwards yeah just like
and just like bond over a pint or
something yes i feel like if we hang out
in the uk during the day
and you know we're we haven't really
said anything it's just like we're
getting drinks later right like that
yeah yeah
like if you're ever a guest on the
podcast probably gonna get drinks after
yeah
we have every single time we do it with
chris we did it with carl yeah
exactly